in the early hours of a September
morning 1940 This Plane a heinkel he-111
was making its way towards London
carrying two tons of bombs to the
densely populated city it may well have
reached its destination if not for the
early Warning Systems the British
military Home Defense had created a
network of radar stations all feeding
into a central operations room where
incoming raid information was ratified
and mapped on a gigantic chart of
Britain it was from this room in Bentley
Priory that all RAF commands during the
Battle of Britain were made this was a
frantic but precise procedure every
minute that passed was a crucial minute
stolen from the pilots vital time needed
to gain altitude to meet the enemy on a
Level Playing Field this groundbreaking
air defense network allowed Britain's
Defenders to be in the air add
interception altitude within 10 minutes
of the first signs of invasion on the
radar screens
this would not have been possible
without aircraft capable of quickly
gaining altitude to meet their folks the
Spitfire is the icon of the Battle of
Britain capable of climbing 760 meters
per minute taking them at minimum four
to five minutes to reach their Target's
altitude
the Spitfire was a Nimble Interceptor a
plane that could rapidly gain altitude
and proceed to fiercely defend its
airspace to do this it needed to be
powerful maneuverable and capable of
packing a punch some of the greatest
Engineers of World War II worked on this
fighter and the designs they came up
with changed the course of the war
this is the insane engineering of the
Spitfire
despite its patriotic Fame the
groundbreaking nature of the spitfire's
design is difficult to comprehend today
in a world where we are long accustomed
to all metal lowing Fighters the
Spitfire despite its undeniable Elegance
may seem mundane however when the
Spitfire first swept through airfields
in 1936 the RAF still operated aircraft
like the Gloucester Gauntlet and the
Hawker Fury biplanes were the norm for
fighters of this era the Stacked Wings
increased the lift the aircraft could
generate while making them stronger and
better able to withstand the g-forces of
Maneuvers but they generated a lot of
drag
Spitfire was made possible by new
powerful engines and new revolutionary
age hardened aluminum Alloys freeing the
spitfire's chief designer RJ Mitchell to
get creative setting out to create a
plane capable of outrunning and
outturning any foe turn performance is
essentially measured by the minimum turn
radius a plane can achieve a tighter
turn radius gives a fighter aircraft an
edge in a dogfight to understand what
affects the radius of this turn we first
need to understand how an aircraft turns
to begin a turn an aircraft will roll in
the direction of the turn this is called
the aircraft Bank angle this splits the
lift the plane is generating into two
components a horizontal component that
causes the plane to turn and a vertical
component that keeps the plane in the
sky a steeper Bank angle will increase
the horizontal component and decrease
the turn radius while stealing lift from
the vertical component this vertical
component needs to equal the weight of
the aircraft or the plane will lose
altitude to compensate for that the
pilots will deflect the plane's
elevators downwards to increase lift but
this also increases drag this increase
in drag means the pilot will also need
to increase engine power to maintain
speed
the maximum turn possible that won't
result in loss of altitude or speed is
called the sustained turn performance
and it's affected by the weight of the
aircraft the Excess power available from
the engine and the design of the Wings
to excel in battle the Spitfire needed
the perfect wing and Mitchell did his
absolute best to give it just that RJ
Mitchell had plenty of experience in
designing Sleek high-performance
aircraft designing the supermarine S5
that won the Schneider trophy in 1928
there was some deliberation on the shape
the spitfire's wing would take with some
early designs like this one from 1934
showing a straight taper unlike the
iconic elliptical wing it eventually
took this would have been vastly easier
to manufacture but the shape a wing
takes has a huge effect on performance
in part particular lift distribution and
the elliptical Wing provides the ideal
lift distribution to minimize induced
drag induced drag occurs when high
pressure air from underneath the wing
travels to mix with the low pressure air
above the wing over the wing tip this
creates a vortices at the wingtip that
sups kinetic energy away from the plane
this elliptical lift distribution
minimizes this effect but RJ Mitchell is
quoted in Alfred prices the Spitfire
story saying this
I don't give a bugger whether it's
elliptical or not so long as it covers
the guns
the reduction in induced drag is often
cited as the sole benefit of the
elliptical Wing when in actuality it
barely made a dent in the overall drag
characteristics of the plane which was
not worth the added difficulty in
manufacturing the real benefits of the
elliptical Wing came from the platform's
slow reduction in cordland take a
straight tapered Wing its cord the width
of the wing steadily decreases from the
root of the wing steadily reducing the
area near the fuselage that can be used
to fit equipment the curve of the
ellipse on the other hand maintains the
width of the wing close to the fuselage
and then drops off more rapidly towards
the wingtips this provides ample room
inside the wing to fit the landing gear
guns Hydraulics radiators and Wing
support structures the room provided to
fit a strong but lightweight Wing spare
is a key benefit that allowed the
Spitfire to take daring turns without
worry of structural failures the
engineers of the Spitfire had a delicate
Balancing Act to perform increasing the
strength of a wing often requires adding
weight and adding weight decreases turn
performance climb performance and
increases fuel consumption the
spitfire's wing is not perfectly
elliptical
trailing Edge turns inwards more rapidly
than the Leading Edge this was done
primarily for structural reasons the
main structural support of the wing is
the wingspan and in the Spitfire it runs
perfectly along the quarter cord of the
wing the quarter cord is located as its
name would suggest a quarter of the way
up the width of the wing it is the
aerodynamic center of the wing where the
overall lift of the wing acts through if
the wing was perfectly elliptical it
would be impossible to place this Wing
spur along the court Accord and the
overall lift force would as a result be
behind the wing spur instead of directly
over it
this would create a twisting motion on
the wing that would require additional
strengthening and weight this is why the
trailing Edge occurs in as it does to
adjust the quarter cord's location to be
in line with the wing spare much was
done to minimize the weight of these
support structures the bending Force the
wing needs to resist decreases as you
travel down the way so the spare can
reduce its strength and weight
throughout the wingspan manufacturing a
complicated shape was not particularly
easy in the 1940s today we can
manufacture single parts to shapes
Engineers of World War II could only
imagine using CNC milling machines to
allow the strength of the Wings bar to
decrease it's constructed from simple
nested Square extrusions the upper and
lower Spar booms were constructed from
five concentric aluminum square sections
which were cut and placed inside of each
other like this this Wing was an
engineering Masterpiece that gave the
Spitfire incredible handling
characteristics when we compare the
Spitfire to the bf-109 its Nemesis
during the Battle of Britain we can
start to make some real deductions about
the effect this Wing had on the plane
the wing area of the spit is noticeably
larger this affects a performance metric
called Wing loading which is simply the
total mass of the aircraft divided by
the wing area this affects the turning
radius of the aircraft a heavier
aircraft with smaller Wings will have a
larger Wing loading and as a result
we'll have a larger turning radius the
bf-109 wings were much smaller and thus
had a higher Wing loading and so the
bf-109 had a larger turn radius than the
Spitfire
while the space afforded by the
spitfire's wings allowed it to fit eight
Browning machine guns inside the wing or
as later variants featured two larger 20
millimeter cannons and four of the
smaller 7.7 millimeter brownies all
mounted inside the wing and outside the
propeller Arc which reduced the
engineering effort needed to integrate
them a luxury the bf-109 did not have
the engineers at messerschmith were
forced to use more complicated designs
to integrate ornaments two machine guns
mounted above the engine could fire
through the propeller blades with an
interrupter gear timing the triggering
to ensure they did not strike the blades
a cannon could be fitted behind the
engine which would fire through a hollow
tube that ran through the inverted V12
engine and through the nose of the
propeller Hub later variants attempted
to correct the disparity in Firepower by
mounting guns inside the wings but there
wasn't enough room for ammunition so a
belt feeder was run through a shoot from
the fuselage to the guns this wasn't a
reliable mechanism some variants did
include gun pods mounted below the wing
which negatively affected the plane's
handling the spitfire's primary role was
an Interceptor to do this it needed a
powerful engine and light airframe the
most important factor for climb rate is
power to rate ratio creating a powerful
engine that could fit into a small
airframe required some of the best mines
in Britain the Merlin engine of the
Spitfire went through many iterations
over the war with the constant goal to
squeeze more and more power out of the
27 liter displacement engine
displacement meaning the volume of the
cylinder swept by each piston the
displacement of an engine has a huge
effect on the total power output power
is derived from fuel burning to create
heat which creates pressure on the
cylinders to do work to increase power
we need to increase the amount of heat
energy released but we can't just add
more fuel without adding more air to
burn it there is an Optimum air fuel
ratio about 12 to 1 12 Parts air to one
part fuel this gets even more
complicated for aircraft that fly
through various altitudes because the
air pressure decreases as we climb air
pressure drops by half at 5 500 meters
which would half the oxygen available to
burn the fuel to combat this the Merlin
featured a supercharger to increase air
pressure air began its journey into the
Merlin engine through the air intake
located underneath the fuselage from
here it first passes the carburetor
where fuel is mixed into the Airstream
the Spitfire utilized a float carburetor
float carburetor is used as the name
would suggest a float the float Works
similarly to the float in your toilet
cistern detecting the fluid level and
controlling a valve to keep it at the
optimum level in the carburetor tank
this became an issue for the Spitfire
when German Pilots learned the engine
would cut out in a negative G maneuver a
negative G maneuver would force the
float down and open the valve flooding
the engine with too much fuel the bf-109
engine utilized direct fuel injection a
more complicated system that required 12
plungers one for each cylinder cams to
time the fuel injection and geared power
from the engine a more complicated
solution that allowed German Pilots to
perform negative Jeep Dives to evade
pursues while Spitfire Pilots needed
extra time to perform a roll before
diving which ensured the dive was made
in positive giving German Pilots
precious time to escape after passing
the carburetor the air entered the
supercharger compressor where the air
was compressed before entering the
Piston increasing the power output of
the engine this system helped the
Spitfire squeeze out extra horsepower
from their 27 liter engine rivaling the
power of the much larger 34 liter db601
engine fitted into the bf-109 during the
Battle of Britain however early Merlin
engines featured a single speed single
stage supercharger the speed of the
supercharger being determined by the
gearing ratio coming from the crankshaft
this forced the engineers to design the
supercharger to work at the optimum
speed and compression ratio for a
particular altitude we can see this when
looking at Power curves that plot the
engine power versus altitude
early Merlin 3 reached Peak power around
10 000 feet before quickly dropping off
you may notice that power output is
actually lower at sea level despite the
ambient air pressure being higher here
that's also a result of the supercharger
speed being fixed in order to prevent
the engine from being over pressured
there was a throttle on the air intake
that gradually opened as the plane
gained altitude while the Spitfire had
excellent power at its Optimum altitude
its bf-109 foes during the Battle of
Britain had Superior power at lower
altitudes because they featured an
ingenious device that allowed their
superchargers to vary their speed their
supercharger was placed at a 90 degree
angle to the engine and power was
transferred to it with a fluid coupling
which uses a fluid to transfer power
from the engine to the supercharger the
input shaft causes a fluid inside the
coupling to rotate around the casing
with a pump which in turn causes is a
turbine attached to the output shaft to
turn
this method of power transmission
allowed the supercharger to operate at
various speeds because the amount of oil
inside the coupling was controlled by a
separate pump which gradually increased
the amount of oil inside the coupling as
the plane gained altitude this prevented
the supercharger from over pressuring
the engine and gave the bf-109 engine
Superior power at lower altitudes
this gave the bf-109e variant which was
most widely used during the Battle of
Britain an edge over the Spitfire while
the Spitfire could outturn the 109 the
109 had a better power to rate ratio
which allowed the 109 to sustain a
climbing turn to outmaneuver a Spitfire
on its tail British Engineers were well
aware of this issue prior to the Battle
of Britain and development began on a
two-stage two-speed supercharger for the
Merlin engine in mid-1940. this allowed
the supercharger to operate at two
different speeds via a gear change but
also introduced a second impeller which
increased the compression for even
better high altitude performance this
increased compression caused an increase
in temperature of the air that would
negatively affect engine efficiency and
so an intercooler had to be introduced
to cool The Supercharged air before
entering during the piston this
intercooler removed 33 percent of the
heat added by the supercharger removing
more heat would have been beneficial but
there is a balancing act here to remove
more heat the plane needed a larger
radiator to dump that heat to atmosphere
and a larger radiator would result in
more drag which negated the power
increase
the radiator design in fact was one of
the chief ways the Spitfire managed to
squeeze so much power out of its smaller
Merlin engine German Engineers had noted
how much smaller the spitfire's
radiators were a knew exactly why in one
meeting between the chiefs of Germany's
Aviation development messerschmith noted
that the spitfire's radiators were half
the size of their own while the head of
German engine development explained to
an indignant government official that to
reduce the radiator size would require
higher coolant pressures which their
engine couldn't tolerate without leaking
the British had developed high pressure
high temperature coolant systems for
their high-speed Racing Engines to
compete in races like the Schneider
trophy the Germans were prohibited from
participating in these Races by the
Treaty of Versailles and so were left
behind in the development of this vital
technology apology increasing the
pressure of the coolant allowed the
engineers to raise the operating
temperature of the coolant without it
boiling an increased temperature
difference between the radiator and the
outside air increased the rate heat
could be radiated away from the plane
and this allowed the spitfire's radiator
to be much smaller this did require the
radiators to be stronger and thus
heavier but the reduction in drag more
than made up for the increased weight
the bf-109 and spitfire were formidable
foes for each other and the difference
between life and death more often than
not came down to the skill of the pilots
and the Strategic advantages the British
had in fighting over their home soil the
Battle of Britain was one on small
margins and the engineers of the
Spitfire did everything they could to
give the Spitfire an edge in battle but
it and the much more numerous Hawker
hurricane would not have stood a chance
without the systems and procedures on
the ground that allowed them to get into
the Air day after day radar data
processing mapping chain of commands
pilot training and even fuel octane
ratings all played a role in winning the
Battle of Britain and I explain it all
and our nebula original series The
Battle of Britain many of the animated
sets including the custom-made
operations room at Bentley Priory that
you saw in this video were created for
that series and that's the level of
quality you can expect from all our
nebula original series there are
currently four episodes available for
you to watch right now with even more on
the way along with their seven part
Logistics of D-Day series or you could
watch my favorite recent original by
Wendover Productions covering the
history of Wake Island a tiny remote
island in the middle of the Pacific with
a rich history in aviation and World War
II if you want to support this Channel
watch our videos ad free including
sponsor messages like this and get to
watch incredible exclusive documentaries
from independent creators join nebula
Now by signing up for the Curiosity
stream and nebula bundle deal for just
14.79 a year
1479 for an entire year membership
giving you access to both nebula and
curiosity streams massive catalog of
educational and entertaining videos and
documentaries